[Music]
hey
foreign
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
hi everyone good evening and welcome to
the table
my name is karen miner and i'm so glad
you're here for this first sunday
of 2021 a new year new beginnings
and new possibilities so welcome
if you could take a moment right now and
comment down below let us know that
you're watching we would
love the chance to say hi to you
personally and welcome you to the
community
you are here for a very special night i
love
our first sunday of the year this is our
second year that we're
kicking off the year with some
storytelling and
it reminds me of something that a friend
of mine ryan bayron
said this has been gosh quite a few
years ago
but he said that a story that lives
is a story that's told and that has
always stuck with me
stories are powerful they're connecting
they're healing they're freeing
something really special when we open up
and share our stories so i'm looking
forward to that tonight
and i'm so glad you're here i just have
one announcement
before we transition over to worship
and that is just a really quick update
about uh meeting in person
uh we are not going to be doing that for
a while
numbers with covet are still
way high and we want to keep everybody
safe
we want to
yeah we want to not max out our
hospitals
um we just want to be thoughtful in the
way we do things and
the best way we can love those around us
right now is to continue meeting online
so that's what we're going to do for the
foreseeable future
and i'm grateful that we have it it's a
um it's been
one of the highlights over the past year
uh just to
be together connect in this way and
to remember that we're all connected and
to keep
just putting jesus at the center of
everything we do so i hope you'll
continue to
join us online and hopefully it won't be
for too much longer
and we'll continue to keep you updated
on that all right
how about if we pray before we move into
worship
god thank you for another sunday
together
thank you for a new year and all that
comes with that
a chance to arrive again to
remember our values and to remember
um yeah what is worth living for
and we do that without erasing the past
so god we give you the stories of last
year and invite you into the stories of
this year
and we say yes
to the things that you're inviting us
into whatever that might be for each one
of us god i pray that you would make us
aware
of the ways that you're inviting us to
grow and mature this year
to be more christ-like and
so we take this opportunity to center on
you
to re-commit
ourselves to you or at least open
ourselves up to that
if we haven't done that before to
remember
god that you are love that you are for
us
and that you are always in our midst
so god i pray for glimpses of your
orchestration glimpses of your goodness
and faithfulness and your glory
i pray for so many moments of that
tonight and throughout this coming year
and we thank you god for what you're
doing and what you will do
in the coming months in our community
and beyond
in jesus name amen
thanks karen hey everybody um
i am with karen i love the first sunday
of the year
i love hearing people's stories and
celebrating them together
um and i just feel like that is the
beauty of church communities
is when we can celebrate um what we've
seen
in each other's lives and come around
each other and
the the worship that we're going to be
doing tonight in various
forms and fashions i'm really excited
let me say up front i'm very excited for
the people who are contributing to our
music tonight namely gary
and matthew and maggie and um
maggie and and
um all the songs
that are going to be a part of this
service
are kind of around the heart of
um people sharing their shirt
their their story the journey that
they've been on and us being able to say
um we believe you're not alone for one
um we're with you in the good moments
and the bad moments
and we believe that god is on your side
um
i just want to read this passage as we
begin
um and just maybe tuck it away in your
mind as you hear different lyrics and
the songs as you hear different parts of
these people's stories as brett's
sharing um
it's from philippians 1 it says i thank
my
god every time i remember you
in all my prayers for all of you i
remember
and i always pray with joy because of
your partnership in the gospel from the
first day until now
being confident of this that he who
began
a good work in you will carry it on to
completion
until the day of christ jesus
and this is my prayer that your love may
abound
more and more in knowledge and depth of
insight
i've seen that happen in people's life
this year where i feel like
i'm getting a first row seat
to love abounding more and more
and in new ways and that takes
vulnerability
a lot of it has been born through pain
and
it's required bravery and humility and
courage and um
and i just am sitting here at the
beginning of 2021
and saying thank you god
thank you for these people thank you for
the thing that you do
in us um
i'm just so grateful for transformation
i'm so grateful that we are alone
and that we can be together on these
journeys and then
[Music]
celebrate when there are things to
celebrate and then
also walk with each other when there are
moments that
we'd rather forget so
here's to god continuing his good work
in us
[Music]
there's a grace when the heart is under
fire
[Music]
space between where i used to be
and this reckoning
i know i'll never be alone
there was another in the fire
standing next to me
there was another in the waters
holding back the seas
[Music]
died for me there is another
i'm
[Music]
between what remains of me
and this reckoning
of this
[Music]
standing next to me
there's another in the waters
holding back
[Music]
set me free there's a grave that holds
power nobody
[Music]
[Applause]
as the darkness
[Music]
as the prison
as the darkness bounced
[Applause]
[Music]
nothing stands between us
but the name that is
between all the things
[Music]
[Applause]
standing next to me
there'll be another in the
[Music]
[Applause]
i'll count the joy
[Music]
[Applause]
i
[Music]
[Applause]
nothing stands between us
nothing stands between
be us in the fire
standing next to me
there'll be another in the water
holding back the seas
and should i ever need reminding
of how good you've been to me
i'll count the joy
cause i know that's where you'll be
i'll count the joys
[Music]
thank you mindy and maggie um yeah fun
fact uh
maggie is a matthews piano teacher and
yeah he's gonna get us started today
in my mother's wounds
you form me with your hands
known in love by you
before i took a breath
when i doubt it lord remind me
i'm wonderfully
you're an artist
and
you make all things
work together
for my future
and for my good
you make all things
work together
for your glory
[Music]
and for your name
there's a healing light
it's just beyond the clouds though i've
walked
clearly now i know nothing
has been wasted
[Music]
you make all things
work together
for my future
and for my good you make
all things work together
for your glory
[Music]
and for your
[Applause]
when i name lord remind me
i'm wonderfully made you're an
artist stands apart i know
nothing has been wasted
no failure or mistake
you're an artist and a potter
i'm the canvas and the play
you make all things
work together
for my future
[Music]
and for my good
you make all things
work together
for your glory
and for your name
not finished with me you're not finished
with me
yet you're not finished with me
oh you're not finished with me yet
i know nothing has been wasted
no failure or mistake you're an
artist and departer i'm the candice and
the claire
you're an artist dance
[Music]
yes so good for so many reasons
i love i love just
watching matthew play and watching you
guys together
and i just oh okay my heart feels so
full right now
um i'm excited
to be able to share um one of the songs
i wrote and we felt like
on this night where we designate the
first week of the
year at the table to share personal
stories um to share a personal song
and this is one that um
was sort of my 2020
process um and sort of
um yeah just my way of working through
some of my
own journey with god um
and um those of you who know me well
would know that i'm um always
a little i'm always trying to find
the um places in my life
where um my relationship for
with god has somehow been um
formed through fear rather than love and
that's just kind of been a
common theme um especially throughout my
um adult life is just kind of
recognizing places where
um yeah maybe it wasn't so much faith
maybe it was more fear
that was guiding me and um
wanting to rewrite that story and
wanting to write it in the nature of
love
and so um this
song is sort of um yeah
a personal story on that account and um
i asked mindy towards the
beginning mid-year maybe mid-year if she
would help me
have a bad habit of starting songs and
never finishing it so she's
she's the unseen editor and co-writer of
every song probably that i've ever
written but this one we tried to be more
intentional
about doing it together so i'm grateful
for that
and she's going to join me in singing it
so we just want to share that with you
guys and
go ahead and share this song as well
we're eyes who cross the ocean
where i to sail the seas
[Music]
you'd be the waves beneath me
and if i crossed over
[Music]
me mother smile to greet
me the father holding me
in the truth is
i could never leave you
even if i try to
you're everywhere i
and go i fear i
have just outrun you
it is there i find you in a place i've
never known
the boundary lines continue to
unfold
to reach from who you are to
what i've known
you'll always be in every place
[Music]
oh
the land the skies
[Music]
and there's no path
that doesn't reach to me
[Applause]
you cross everybody
[Music]
inside your mysteries
and the truth is
i could never leave you
even when i try to
you're everywhere i go
i have just outrun you
it
[Music]
the is lines continue to
unfold
to reach from who you are to
what i've
you'll known be in every place
i go oh
there's never been a space you
did not know
you are boundless
that was lovely i think that's my first
time here that song
really really lovely thank you maggie
and mindy and
um good evening to all of you grace and
peace
welcome welcome to the table i'm i'm
just so glad
you know i'm glad hey y'all we made it
20 20.
no problem
um we are we're here we're survivors and
uh i'm i'm glad just really really
grateful to be
you know with you all and um you know
before we jump into more things i wanted
to
just name right off the bat um that a
i'm so grateful
for all of you brave souls who attended
our outdoor christmas eve
service that north wind was a blowing
uh and we did it originally we scheduled
for 3 30 because we thought
more people could make it plus um
the we thought the weather you know
might be a little warmer but nope it was
the opposite the wind was blowing at 3
30 and by 7 pm it had died down
so anyway thank you for um just for
joining us and to those who watched
online um
you know like you're not quite as
hardcore but we still love you
and i'm i am glad that you joined us in
that way
um so and also a huge thank you to all
the folks who
basically helped make that whole service
possible um
mindy reynolds of course on the worship
team for doing all of the music that
takes
a lot of time and sarah johns her
hospitality team
did a lot of kind of behind the scenes
work and uh and then also gary miner and
scott johnson
they pulled off christmas miracles y'all
on the uh audio visual tech side of
things
so i'm grateful just for all of those um
amazing amazing
rock stars and i mean i shudder to think
where i'd be
without without this broader team so
um yeah thank you guys so much all right
so let's shift
gears uh tonight as has been mentioned
uh it's a very special night because
here at the table
um we are gonna do our second annual
so now it's like a thing second uh story
sunday
and uh basically the idea is that to
kick off each year we like to
just start by reflecting a bit you know
on where we've been
uh and something uh i believe is that
you know all of us we're not so much
just human beings having the occasional
spiritual experience
but that that deep down in our cores um
that that we are really spiritual beings
having a human experience in other words
there's this
inner journey the journey of of the
heart of the mind of the soul
you know that the process by which we
are um
waking up to god we're growing
up into the image of christ and then
that empowers us to you know show up in
the world being people of faith hope and
love
um so in so many ways uh
pretty stylish too
um sorry about my mic hitting nothing um
so as i was saying just that that it's
about this
you know this inner journey um and uh
and so basically what we want to do is
kind of create the space for people
to be able to share their story really
the story of where they've been the
challenges that they faced
and just what they're learning about you
know god themselves the world
and and and kind of the idea is that in
the process of them
sharing that that's not only helpful and
insightful for
them um it's also incredibly encouraging
and
enlightening for us because we begin to
see ourselves
and um and those we love you know um
in their stories so with that in mind
we're going to have two very special
people
who will be sharing with us tonight and
the first
is someone who uh you know although you
may not recognize her
um she's been a faithful member at the
table for a number of months now
and her name is mariah kent
so mariah is yeah here she is
hello friend hello hello welcome
thank you i'm so glad you could be here
and um so a few months back mariah and i
we
grabbed coffee um that's been a good way
for me to connect with folks is some
outdoor coffee slots and so um
when we did that mariah i was just so
struck by your story and
so i've been really excited um just to
have others kind of be brought into the
loop to be able to hear it
um and just to get to know you and to
really glean some wisdom
from some of the experiences that you've
had so uh how about
you start off just by sharing with us
you know a little bit about
yourself where you're from any family
info
how you found the table uh you know all
those sorts of things
yeah great so as brett mentioned my name
is mariah
um i am from texas um so
right here um i grew up in the colony
um i have an amazing husband his name is
cody
um and a cute dog his name is finn
um and he's snoring in the background so
i apologize if you hear him
um and yeah i found the table just by
looking
um i was looking for a church that fit
my values and that's where you know i
found the table
cool well we are glad that you found us
so um so you've um
in kind of sharing i i realized pretty
quickly in your story that you've
really you've kind of had this whole
journey out of
a rather toxic um kind of a church
situation
um and and i get like you know to some
degree like any human community
we all have our dysfunctions i mean
every family every you know
every church every organization um but
you're you know
the experience you've had really of of
your your former community it's
um it's held you know a lot of pain for
you so
i wondered could you just go ahead and
share with us just some of the
you know the backstory like what what
was that context like what was it like
growing up
there um because it's really you know
extends back into like childhood
um absolutely so i grew up in
a church family and my parents are both
military
and so i had a very strict upbringing
just in general um but then on top of
that my mom found
the church that i was raised in when i
was one years old
and so i was raised in that church
almost from birth
um from as long as i can remember um
and there's a lot of great um things but
there's also a lot of
very controlling and strict things as
well
um and so from what i can remember
there was not a whole lot about the love
of god
um and the mercy and grace of god
more of how god could smite you
um you know if you did wrong by him um
and so
um much like it was shared in worship i
grew up
in a a place where i was
driven by fear um instead of
you know love and knowing um the true
power of god
that i feel like i'm still learning now
um
so kind of practicals there is you um
you have a church family and it's a very
large church family
um and you go to church three times a
week standard
and then there's also other uh church
gatherings usually about five i would
say a week that you are
basically required to go to if you're
not there or somebody is calling you and
asking you
if you're on your deathbed because
that's where you should be if you're not
there
um your friends groups are in this
church you date within this church
and i just remember as a child feeling
lonely i wasn't able to go to sleepovers
and
um i didn't have prom in homecoming
um so just things that i was not able to
do
um because of the rules and the
the community
you it sounds like the um
kind of the ethos the the vibe the
culture of this of this church community
was kind of one of
a lot of control um yeah and
i i wondered were there were there like
any other
kind of red flags you know experiences
that you had that kind of
tipped you off probably maybe as you got
older because of course you know when
you're like six years old or whatever
like
you don't tune into this is odd um
so as you got older you know what were
or were there any other
things kind of red flags um that you had
um i think that even from a young age
i started to see uh
things that i didn't particularly
particularly
um agree with um namely i felt like
i wasn't allowed to be an individual or
ask any questions
and you're just kind of basically a
soldier
right you just follow um and you do what
you're told to do
and asking questions is bad
um you know and you just don't you don't
have your own individual life
and it's really about uh everybody
together um you know obeying
god's commands and the bible um directly
and not
necessarily your own individual
experience
and so as i got older i really wrestled
with having an identity
i just felt like i wasn't allowed to be
a person
um and i was scared to have my own
you know likes and hobbies and um
friends you know um because everything
was by the book and you had to do
everything the way they told you to do
it
and so that was kind of a red flag for
me
another red flag for me and growing up
was
um homosexuality and it's always been
something
that i have strongly um disagreed with a
mainstream
vision of that's not allowed
and i had questions you know i didn't
understand why
there was no love when all i felt was
love
um you know for anybody that was
different from me
um anybody that was the same as me you
know and
um so i just didn't i didn't understand
that i had a lot of questions those
questions weren't allowed
uh so those were kind of red flags for
me yeah
yeah was there um
[Music]
i mean obviously there were a lot of
challenges you know from that season in
your life i am wondering
you know looking back on it were there
are there kind of moments or places
experiences that that you can kind of
see like god's grace
in other words you know whether i guess
was there good
from that you know that season or if
it's things you learned about yourself
or god or
or others but i don't know is there
anything you you kind of glean as
as valuable from that season or was it
just such a
negative experience it's like i'm just
no
so yeah in the moment i feel like it was
definitely negative
right um but looking back i feel like
i've i've learned tons from
that experience in my life um i think
for
myself i've learned how to be an
individual um i have a voice now i'm
able to
you know have hobbies and friends that
you know
we enjoy hanging out together and um
we're not
exactly alike which i love i love having
friends with differences than me
um it's probably one of my favorite
things about leaving that community
um i think what i've learned the most
about god is that
um he is there he's constantly there
um regardless if i left or
um not he's always been with me
and that's been such a cool thing to
learn
um because even though i left
and i tried to forget he was still
fighting behind the scenes and wrestling
you know for me um and i just felt
i still i feel so loved by that um
because i didn't feel that you know um
when i was a child
uh and i also learned about other people
that
um you know that there is differences
between people
it's okay to have different ideas and
different thoughts
um and i think that you know that that's
something that's been really big is
to learn to accept people's differences
and and love people um
even though they may have different
ideas and thoughts than i do
yeah yeah what um what did it
like was there kind of a breaking point
or or what
you know what was it that um eventually
led you to kind of like
okay i've gotta move forward you know
um and then and then what did it look
like for you to actually
do that um you know what were some of
those experiences the highs the lows
what was that like so kind of what led
you to it and then
what was it like as you would it looked
like as you did it
yeah um so the
i guess there was the red flags were
kind of leaders um
to me leaving um but
i had what as i got older i i knew that
that's
this is where i wanted to be um and it
just became more apparent
um when you become
a member of that church um you're
required to go through
um different steps um one of those steps
is to
um go through and describe
every sin that you've ever committed um
to a group of people
um which sounds hard um just
saying it out loud but it's even harder
when you're there um
and so because i was a teenager and i
was a minor
and my parents were in the church i not
only had to share this information with
the people
that i was going through these steps
with but then also with my mom
um and so uh when i was going through
um that step i discussed with her
um that i have feelings for women and
men
um the same uh it doesn't make a
difference to me and of course i didn't
know what that meant at the time
um but i just remember her looking at me
and saying
no you don't continue um
and so then i just continued down the
list of all the sins
that i had ever committed um and i
just pretended like that part of me
didn't exist
for a long time um and then when
my brother came out um i watched him
struggle um and it was just a hard
struggle
you know um feeling less loved
um you know by my community by my family
and so i remember leaving
was such a hard even
thought to think of right um this church
is so big
um and it's an international church uh
so
if you move you're in expected to go to
a place that has another church
um so i did that but i did that very
intentionally
i'm going to a small a very very small
church um and it made it a lot easier to
leave
because those people didn't know me um
but
when i left it was very quickly spread
throughout all of the churches and not
just the small one that i was in
um so my home church back here in dallas
they knew
within days of me leaving that i had
left
and so i lost my family that i grew up
with since i was one years old
um i think i had exactly two friends
from that church
um remaining when i left um and so
there's just a lot of
loneliness and a lot a lot of lows
during that time period
yeah yeah that's
that seems to be one of the challenges
of coming out of an environment like
that is because of that sense of kind of
control and like
we will be your everything you're almost
well like you mentioned you're not
encouraged to have relationships outside
of it
that's kind of frowned upon and like oh
you're strained from the flock
and so what happens is that does become
your everything
which makes it so hard to leave um
and that was something that stood out to
me just as as we had
um our first conversation i was thinking
oh my gosh
like the courage it took for you to to
take that step
um to i mean in many ways to kind of say
like look
this is who i'm going to be and i've got
to create i mean almost a whole new
life is that kind of what it feels like
like just a absolutely
because then i had my identity right i
had no friends i had no identity
um you know and i was just like what do
i do now
you know yeah so so you take the step
you
you kind of make the break and you start
forging this you know new life just for
a little context like how long ago was
that
and then can you share a little bit just
since then
what's that experience been like for you
you know what have you
what have you learned um so it's been
about seven years
uh since i left i left at 22
and so for contacts that's way more many
years of my life than i've been out you
know
um and there's just a sense of guilt
that comes with it
um and in that church uh it's
it's very uh common uh commonly said
that this is the only way
you know so it didn't matter what other
church i went to because i felt like
i was just a fraud you know if i didn't
go to that church
i wasn't going to go to heaven um and
that
feeling lasted until this past year when
i found the table
and i've tried so many different
churches
i've tried pretending like god doesn't
exist um i've tried
you know a bunch of different things to
fix this guilt in my heart um
and and i really feel like it took
finding the right church
um finding the right community that
believes the way that i believe to get
me out of that
guilt-ridden past you know
yeah what what do you think it's been
about the past year
or coming to the table or just what
god's done
in your heart and mind in this season
you know what
was it the i mean because obviously we
haven't even necessarily been meeting in
person
so it's not like oh it's the hugs of all
the people every sunday
um i what do you what do you think that
yeah how has god used it and i i don't i
don't want to frame this in a way that's
like
tell me all the awesome things about the
table that's not really what i mean i
just mean you know what's
what is it god's used um you know to die
um and that was very recently um so i
think
you know for me uh when i left seven
years ago i
had to sing the same prayer in my heart
for seven years
and like i said there was times when i
didn't believe but i continued praying
that prayer
um and it was that god would change my
heart of stone
into a heart of flesh um and there's a
scripture that resonates with that but
at the time i didn't
know that um so at the beginning of this
year i read that scripture
um and i was just gushing with tears
um and it's just so crazy that 2020 was
such a negative year
for so many and i feel like it was
probably one of the most positive years
of my life
um because i was just searching um and i
prayed that god would help me find what
i was searching for
um and i feel like it had nothing to do
with me but everything to do with god
pointing me in this direction
of the table um and just a community
i i see online and people are just
messaging
um and you know shouting out other
people and
the worship um and just your realness
every sunday
is just exactly what i'm looking for um
and it's been awesome so far beautiful
as you as you kind of look ahead to
um i mean what's what are you kind of
hopeful for
what um are you yeah kind of looking
forward to what's what's kind of your
posture as you're like looking ahead i'm
really excited i'm really excited for
i think that um now finding this
community i feel like
even more excited to just know more
people learn about more people
and hear their stories and you know
hopefully we'll get to meet in person at
some point this year
um you know i'm praying for that uh and
just
you know continuing to grow you know i
definitely don't have all the answers
by any means but um continue to learn
and to continue to grow
yeah well mariah thank you so much for
sharing
and we are um we're just better for
having you
as part of us um your presence means so
so much
and and thank you for having the courage
to like open up and share about you know
uh probably even memories and things
from a life you know or part of your
life that you'd rather just kind of like
leaving it behind so thank you for um
opening up
in in that way we're really really
grateful
thanks yeah all right y'all give her
like a virtual hand or something
i don't know if we can if it's in the
comment section that's how we do this so
anyway thank you so much mariah thank
you guys
uh she's amazing so
uh last but not least tonight i wanted
to have
uh my good friend glenda veyron
come up and share come up come on
and share so her and her husband
um hey glenda uh her husband ryan
they've been um they're good good
friends of mine they've been hugely
instrumental in helping us
launch really kind of both of the
churches that we've started
and um she's a very i would describe
glenda glenda's a very strong person
but she's very gentle at heart when you
get to like
see that side of her and so hopefully
some of that will will come out tonight
i think it will
and um so welcome welcome glenda thanks
so can you um just start by
you know just tell us a bit about about
yourself kind of you're where you're
from
ryan you know whatever you want to share
um i
am well i guess i'm from here ish
um i am a child of a single mother and
i'm one of four
girls of a single mother um and
it's a it was a very blended family only
two of us share the same dad and so
we kind of moved wherever she could find
work she was a nurse
and so um but i finally i settled roots
or i put roots down
in the metroplex and
we currently live in rowlett i have a
husband ryan
um and a son named bricks
and i teach i'm a high school teacher so
and just a little preface i feel like i
should let you know this just so you can
kind of know i am an enneagram eight
so all of this vulnerability
um is a lot
yes yeah you're you're being courageous
my friend
and i'm really grateful um so
this i was thinking like in many ways
your story kind of contrasts with
mariah's because for her this year has
been kind of one of like
breakthrough and like yes and for you
this is well in a way it's been that
more towards maybe the end of the year
but this has been a heck of a year
just profoundly profoundly challenging
so
um and really it kind of extends back
you know even into i think 2019 so maybe
um take us back a bit um
to when things kind of kicked off in
terms of just
starting to take a certain a really
difficult challenging turn
um you might even say kind of when
things start to unravel a bit
um what you know what brought it about
what did what did that kind of look like
so
um i am a child of trauma
and i have carried that with me for a
very long time
and i had some issues with counseling as
a child so i
kind of wrote that off and decided
it's not for me but i really needed to
be
in therapy um and so as i was going
through
my adult life it was just kind of like
okay pull yourself up by your bootstraps
and just survive basically and
that all came to a head and
there was really just this one
culminating event where
um i ultimately
almost lost everything um
and it was at the end of 2019
and it was my own actions that caused it
um and so i had made some choices
um and i had reverted back to what i had
learned
as a child on how to you know resolve
conflict
and so i'll just be 100 on i was abusive
and so um i had some people step in
and my walls immediately went up
and um i pretty much shut everyone out
and um i i went
into the protection mode like i am a
self preset so i
i was like i'm surviving this i will
come out on top
um and really like my marriage
was almost um
over and i had to like kind of face the
music with that
i had shut some friends out that um one
of them
that i have been friends with since i
was 13 and i'm 34
35 i don't actually know how old i am um
and so uh i've we've been friends longer
than
we haven't been friends and then it just
kind of started bleeding into everything
my cocooning just started shutting
everyone out
i started seeing everyone as an attack
and i couldn't really see the
friendships that were there
and so it just seemed like every time i
turned around
i just there was just another wall
another wall another wall
yeah yeah so it really was this kind of
experience of of
um this kind of one one
moment or one experience where you like
you mentioned you kind of became this
kind of abusive
and and like you said it does it boots
back to your childhood this is kind of
how you've learned to
take care of yourself defend yourself
you know and so you do that
and then that kind of walling up
then starts to spill over into all these
other relationships i mean i'm sure
you maybe you had at least a few
outside of a certain friend group or
something but i mean it was i mean i
kind of as someone from the outside
looking in
it was like a lot of relationships all
of a sudden
like whoa whoa whoa whoa um
that must have been unbelievably like
just even emotionally difficult like
what was
what was that like just even in your own
kind of experience i mean were
were you aware of what you're
kind of doing or was it and and or was
it more like
these people are nuts you know or what
was your
how did you experience that i was aware
of what i was doing but i also
like i'm gonna make sure
that i am in the right whatever
so it was also like okay this is what
i'm being forced to do this is who i'm
being forced to become
and um it was a lot of
just and it was it was very lonely um
just kind of realizing because
i am actually really
thankful for i have a really strong
group
of girls and actually they're very
gracious
and at one point i had just blamed all
of them
for the things that had happened in our
relationship rather than taking
any of the ownership
and so it was just kind of like nope i'm
done
i'm over it you know just cutting my
losses before i could be hurt
yeah wow that's a huge statement
this that sense of cutting your losses
before you can be hurt
um so there you are kind of with
you know these cutting your losses
and um and you're kind of living in the
midst of a lot of broken relationships
you know what was the or was there kind
of a tipping point
or was it just the cumulative effect
like what i'm wondering kind of what led
you to pursue some outside help
you know like you mentioned counseling
or that world was like
just based on some experiences you'd had
previously what what was it that
that made made you kind of pursue that
or led you to pursue that
so it was kind of an agreement between
my husband and i um in
working in like in order to work through
our marriage
um he was like you really need to try it
again
and so i was like okay i'll try the
texting counseling
but if you know me i am very
smart when i can work things
and so i realized like that wasn't doing
anything
for me and so then i started
face-to-face counseling
um and i kind of realized like okay
these two people they're not really
addressing things they're just kind of
talking me through
they're coaching me through and i have
also a really good friend aaron brown
some of you know him he talked on one of
the tables
panels but he's also a
psychiatrist um and so uh
i had been talking to him and he was
like no you really need some trauma
therapy that's really what you needed
and at the same time he had agreed to be
my husband's
like our marriage counseling marriage
counselor
and it wasn't until i met with him that
he was really like
this is all about your mom
like this everything you're responding
you're responding to the world as if
they were your mother
and they're not and so that was really
kind of where it all started and then it
just became
like the rolling that the snowball
rolling down the mountain yeah yeah
because you started to see how
that played out in this situation in
that situation
that that kind of um
yeah kind of unwinding the the ball of
yarn so to speak
what um what was that like when you got
into that kind of counseling setting
did that you know pretty quickly become
aware did or
you became aware of it or did you kind
of fight it like i'm wondering what was
that you know kind of experience like
um and then you know did you learn to
kind of
gain other insights just through that
that process of kind of
counseling and talking with um with
aaron in the midst of it
oh i fought it a lot and there were
several times like in the session he
would be like stop
you can't do that and then i was also
i'm a big researcher i have a degree in
english i teach
english for a living and so i'm big on
getting
information and if you know anything i
know people are like oh the enneagram
an eight goes to a five when they're um
in stress
which means like we try to get we're
data diggers to support ourselves
um the unhealthy side of a five not the
healthy side of the five
um and so i did a lot of research and i
actually came upon
um this instagram account called
the holistic psychologist and then
another one called the truth doctor and
they introduced me to this idea of
re-parenting
which i've never heard of before and
it's really
looking back at your parent and how you
were parented
and reevaluating that and saying they
were the wrong
in the wrong here i need to figure out
how to break that down
and let it go and see like this is what
should have happened
and so just kind of seeing all of that
stuff and making sure that that doesn't
influence who i am today
and a process of letting it go and so
that whole idea of re-parenting
and figuring out like all of that stuff
my mom did was wrong
that doesn't mean the rest of the world
has to pay for it
and so that's a powerful statement
um and that's like one of those
statements that's like easy to make
now but hard fought for yes
like you have to go to hell and back to
say that kind of thing
you know yeah um
i don't i don't know to what degree you
um are comfortable sharing about
especially your your mom in that kind of
context so you can share as little or as
much as you want there but i'm wondering
if
if folks could have a little more feel
for what what
was it you were responding to or
reacting to from
childhood and again you don't have to
share details you're not comfortable
with but
you know when you say it was it was
difficult or traumatic or whatever
um yeah is there anything you feel
comfortable sharing to give us a little
insight into that
what that kind of looked like or meant
yeah um my mom
was and actually still is um
very verbally abusive and she was very
physically abusive towards
me and my three sisters um
and so there was a time i think she was
i
often say she was done being a mom by
the time she had me and she let me know
how little she valued me and
i go back to the only thing i
ever wanted was to be able to cry with
her
and for like to lay down in her lap and
for her to rub my hair kind of like you
see in the movies
um and that was just never an option the
first time i remember her saying she was
proud of me
was in front of other people at my high
school graduation
and so every other time it was just kind
of like oh
yeah you're here and i mean the physical
abuse had led me
to being in foster care when i was eight
um
and there was also a lot of emotional
abuse
and psychological abuse and um
[Music]
she just i she also had some mental
illnesses that she was not dealing with
herself
and that she was not acknowledging and
so
i was the last child at home so i became
the main focus for all of her abuse
because my other sisters left
they all left at 14 and never looked
back
and then my mom had um
she had a stroke my freshman year of
college and i thought like this was
going to be her second chance
everything was going to be better and as
ryan and i would go and pick her up for
dinners and stuff like that she slowly
started reverting back to her old ways
and ryan finally looked at me one day
and he goes you know you're an adult
and you don't have to take this anymore
and i was like oh
i that's true yeah it's true and so
we've actually been distanced since then
yeah so it's it's almost like that's
that was kind of a one defying moment
where you started to kind of
differentiate from from her and like hey
boundaries you know
right um but the the tricky part was you
took
those ways of relating that you had
learned as a young child
and of course you bring that into all of
your closest relationships
which it then starts to wreak you know
complete havoc
and um it's like you it's like there's
multiple levels of distancing
you know and that was some of where
maybe a better metaphor is the onion you
know it's like one layer was
undone but there were other ones to
um to undo um
what um i'm wondering okay so you're
going to counseling
you start getting these this these
insights
um and what did that path kind of
towards healing um
and reconciliation look like for you
because you mentioned kind of the walls
so there were a lot of
kind of um not even just kind of injured
but almost
borderline just broken relationships um
what what did that kind of path towards
healing and and some sort of
reconciliation
um and not that they're all everything
was great now but you know but just what
is that kind of looked like
so um two of my very closest friends um
we had been having ongoing conversations
and they had wanted to have kind of a
can we get together face to face and
talk about this rather than
via any kind of digital communication
and i wasn't in a place and then they
they're faithful enough to reach out
again after many months and say hey this
is really still on our hearts
um and can we please get together and
after that at that time i had done a lot
of the re-parenting and the self-healing
um that the holistic psychologist kind
of talks about and
um i had worked through a lot of that
um and so i was
ready and willing to have that
conversation on top of having
my counseling sessions with aaron and
ryan um
and so we kind of had a conversation and
um
you could tell well they even told me um
when they after they had the
conversation was they were like we were
not expecting
this kind of an outcome because i
basically explained to them everything
and there was a lot of ownership um
that's the hard part
that like i can do all of the work in
the dark
but it's coming back and taking some
ownership for some stuff
that really isn't fun and so that's
really what i ended up doing with all of
my friends
was going back and being like hey
i did some really awful things and i
said some really awful things and i even
had
some not great intentions so
like even letting them know some things
that like they weren't even aware of
and just being a hundred percent honest
because i realized like that's what
it needed that's what it would take
yeah i mean even that that statement you
just made about
even some of my intentions weren't good
like isn't that what we'll kind of hide
behind like i know i said and did all
this
crappy stuff but my heart it was i was
in a good place
i didn't do it for good you know so to
be able to even own like
not even all of my intentions were good
oh my gosh that's um
i i was um particularly close to some of
the people that you're talking about and
so
i know when they recounted to me that
some of that conversation
my jaw was on the absolute floor i was
like
oh my gosh like she owned it what
because i just knew
that is so hard that's
so hard to say like
it was my fault you know or like
and of course everyone has things to own
and stuff but in this situation
look this one was mostly me and yeah
here's what it is
and like just to own it at that level
like
that's absolutely remarkable and i just
want to
i've told you this but i want to
publicly name like just the courage
it took for you to do that and the inner
strength oh it's it's incredible glenda
it's incredible and i'm i'm so so
grateful that you've um
kind of like chosen that path it's just
incredibly powerful
so um i'm wondering what
you know i'm sure people are listening
to this and they're kind of resonating
maybe with some of your story
um and i'm wondering you know for
someone who's maybe had some of that
those traumatic experiences they kind of
suspect
that it's playing out today in their
relationships but it like scares them to
death to go down that road and like sort
of to look in those closets so to speak
i'm wondering you know would you have
any like advice or input
um for someone who kind of sees
themselves in your you know in your
journey
i think you just have to be 100 honest
with yourself um i think you really have
to
beyond talking to anybody else looking
at it and being a hundred percent honest
like with you
with the person in the mirror like you
know michael jackson you gotta start
there
because um i could ignore
everyone i i can ignore everyone and
tout
my own story and you know
believe in that 100 but it really
started with me
being honest with myself and it really
looking and saying you know what is the
role i played like
i mean even now that's the question that
i look at is
okay this is affecting me and it's
affecting me like i feel
anger i feel sad i feel lonely i feel
left out but why
and rather than placing that onus on
someone else
looking at like what part did i play in
it because the minute you start going
outside of yourself
you can't control that and that's really
what self-healing is about is i can't
control what my mom did to me
i can't control what she did to my
sisters i can't control the choices my
sisters are now making
i can't control the choices my husband
makes but what i can do is i can look at
that and make sure
that i am doing
what is healthy what is whole
what is i don't like the word right
but what is in the good for all involved
aaron always use this how can we make
this a win-win for everybody
yeah and so that's a really good idea is
how can this be
a win-win for everybody because i'm that
self-pressed i'm like
it will be a win for me
bring someone else there i will win yeah
and so making it a win-win for everybody
and also
seeing the heart because all of those
friends
when i was talking to them all of them
said thank you and i love you
i tried i tried
but i say and some of those are through
text
and i have them and i mean
just grace upon grace is and whenever
you're honest with yourself and you're
able to accept that
and um yeah
that's beautiful what's um
what's it been like now you know like
here you are it's it's been a few months
this is i mean
we're not talking about things that
happened six months ago it's been what
maybe
two-ish months three months yeah
yeah so it's you know a little time but
not yesterday but not
you know early in the year or something
so i'm wondering what's it
has your experience or what's it like
today like are you in a place where it's
sort of like
i'm just walking out the healing i'm
feeling a lot better is it just very
up and down each day like i'm wondering
you know how yeah how are you
experiencing it
now i think it's
not a one and done it's definitely not a
one and done
um we are using the phrases and when my
friends came over that night
my husband and i started using this
phrase rewriting the narrative
i for the past we've been friends for
seven years i've been married for 12
years
for the past that many years have
written a narrative for these people
and so with this healing and this change
i
have to rewrite that narrative and all i
asked them was the chance to rewrite
that narrative
can you please give me that chance and
um
[Music]
that they were of course way willing um
to give me that chance
but it's something that i have to
constantly look at and i have to go okay
is this behavior the behavior i want to
do
i want to have is this behavior i want
to
rewrite my narrative with um and really
kind of reevaluate those situations do i
want to be fast
and quick and respond immediately do i
want to hide and hold and hoard emotions
until they explode and then let them
spew on everybody
or do i just want to be a hundred
percent honest
and you know let them know in the
beginning hey
this is really uncomfortable for me but
this is who i am now so here goes
and so it's it's a day-to-day journey
every time i encounter something new
it's okay let's reevaluate
so there are some ups and downs but it's
not a one and done
it's definitely you've got to make that
decision every day and
it's totally worth it
so it is hard it's hard whenever you see
all your friends have a party
and you're not there and you then have
to go
ugh i'm so offended that i wasn't
invited but then you have to step back
and you have to go
oh okay what part did i play
in not getting invited and so
like looking at it that way rather than
they hurt me so badly
yeah yeah it sounds
um it's like you've gained this
kind of insight and now you kind of what
i hear you naming is
it's so challenging to walk it out in
this day and day out way
but it's so worth it um because i can
imagine folks
kind of hearing this thinking like oh my
gosh that sounds like a lot
um but the thing is even to avoid it or
to not deal with it
that's also a lot yes you know that
comes with its own
set of consequences and ways
it plays out in your life and um
so kind of what i hear you naming is
like it's worth it
um even though it's hard is that yeah
and that hiding part you're doing it all
alone
whenever you're actually walking it out
you have your people
so i can be like hey this is really hard
and they're like i know it's really hard
how can we you know come alongside you
how can we you know support you in this
and things like that
but when you're holding it all and
you're holding it in and dealing with it
and putting up those walls you're alone
yeah yeah
yeah you're amazing thank you you're
amazing and it's been
um i know a heck of a year for you but
i'm believing for really good things for
you
in 2021 and um
i'm just i'm so grateful for how you've
you know walk this out and i'm also just
grateful for
um your friendship the courage you've
shown
um and in that ability or that that
uh decision to take personal ownership
you know our world would be so much
better if we could all live into that
it's like the hardest thing in the world
but um i'm just i'm so grateful for your
example of
just learning to walk that out that's a
powerful
challenge i think i know it is to me um
and and i know for everyone listening so
um thank you so much for just making
those decisions um this past year and
just for your willingness to um you know
be with us tonight
and to share so thank you so much my
friend you're very welcome
thank you y'all i want to go ahead
and uh pray for us that was
those are powerful huh i'm so grateful
for these two ladies they're
amazing amazing so let's uh let's pray
and just ask god to
kind of seal everything we've heard in
in our hearts so lord i i just thank you
for the vulnerability the honesty
and openness of both mariah and glenda
and there's so many
insights and lessons for us in that in
their stories and so god i ask for the
courage
to embrace what you're speaking and
saying
i believe god that you're speaking to
some people right now
and calling them
to maybe some scary places but to some
good places
so i pray courage over them
i pray a sense of boldness
um desire god to find
healing and hope god and i pray that
this 2021 would be a year
um of connection of
hope of love of forgiveness of
reconciliation of personal ownership
got a year where we just take huge
strides
in becoming more like you god so do that
work in our hearts and minds
we love you in christ saying i pray amen
oh my gosh you guys i'm like my lips are
quivering my hands are shaking
i'm just like these stories
that these powerful women are telling
are just rocking my world
and um i'm just so grateful to you guys
uh thank you so much um
we are better for you and for your
vulnerability and i
just
um i wanted to close tonight with now
i'm thinking this was a
bad idea but i wanted to close with this
song called daughter
um it's by one of my favorite artists
um he goes under the name sleeping at
last and
oh and i just what i love about this
song
is it's it's really a message like from
you know it was written as as a message
from a parent
to someone who's in the role of a
daughter and
um and to me it's just this beautiful
sentiment of someone who's just
always going to believe in you someone
who's always going to be there
and be beside you and and walk out
life with you cheering you on and
oh man i wish the church was like that i
wish we were known for being people like
that i wish like our communities
our faith communities were like labeled
as like
cheerleaders for people you know someone
who's always gonna believe the best
someone who's always gonna be by your
side
um people who are always going to hold
space for you
i just feel like that is that's the
beauty
of of of what a church community can be
and i just i know i'm a broken record
tonight saying it but
these stories have only reconfirmed that
sentiment in my heart
and i just feel like we get the
opportunity to be a voice of compassion
and celebration for other people and
believe in the ongoing work that god is
doing in their life
and sometimes we're believing for them
even when they can't believe for
themselves
sometimes that means we're holding space
in the really
ugly raw horrible moments
and that is a privilege that we get
because then on the other side you hear
stories like this where people's lives
are transforming
and their love is abounding and you get
to be a witness to that journey
and i'm just my heart is so grateful and
i am probably gonna butcher this song
but the intent of it was just to be
a gift spoken on behalf of our community
towards
all of us who have our own stories and
our own journeys that we're going
through but specifically tonight for
mariah and glinda
um just for us to be the people who are
standing beside them
and saying like we see the good and we
believe it on your darkest days
and we celebrate it on your brightest
days and
this is what you know i wish i wish this
is the song that
people heard from their parents um that
was just such a powerful story and
so here we go we're gonna try this
if only you knew
[Music]
you lift your chin a little higher
you open your eyes a little wider
you speak your mind a little louder
cause your
royalty this
is your kingdom this is your crown
this is your story
this is your moment don't look down
is
[Music]
foot in front of you
if only you knew the forest grows a
little greener
our woods reached down a little deeper
the birds all seem a little sweeter
oh to welcome you
i wanna see
[Music]
this is your kingdom this is your crown
this is your story
this is your moment don't look down
[Music]
is
if only you knew
this is your kingdom this is your crown
this is your story
this is your moment don't
[Music]
foreign
thanks mindy that was beautiful what a
night
ah what a great start to the new year
um mariah and glenda thank you so much
for sharing
courageously vulnerably honestly
humbly as you both were sharing it
reminded me of this quote from
marianne rodmaker i don't know if i'm
saying her last name correctly but it
says
courage doesn't always roar sometimes
courage
is the quiet voice at the end of the day
saying i will try again tomorrow
so we hope that the service
resonated with you blessed you reminded
you that you're not alone
and we do really really want to be a
church community that comes alongside of
you
and encourages you in your darkest days
and celebrates
the bright spots with you as well so if
there's any way we can be there for you
whether it's listening prayer tangible
needs please let us know send us a
message over facebook and we will get in
contact with you
also if you resonate with the vision and
the values and what we're doing here at
the table
we would love to continue to do what
we're doing and to allow
uh just more people to be a part of it
and
for our work that we feel god has called
us to do to flourish
you can give through our website which
is
thetabletx.org any amount is so
appreciated and goes a long way towards
helping us continue that so as you
go into your week and continue into the
new year
let me leave you with this blessing
you are a child of god this is true
on your best days and it's true on your
worst days
you are wonderfully and lovingly made
there is only
one you nothing about you
is a mistake and this world needs you
being
fully yourself authentic and free
so as you go into the year ahead with
it's yet to be determined
highs and lows and everything in between
go with the assurance that you are loved
you are worthy and you are accepted just
as you are
and go filled with god's holy spirit and
the desire to extend
these same gifts of grace and
unconditional love
to everybody you come in contact with be
blessed
we hope to see you back here next sunday
bye
you